likely to be the biggest challenge when
it comes to a general election and
making sure that uh we keep a
conservative government she had to
delete a tweet penny mordent today uh
telling mps that a vote for rishi sunek
or liz trust would murder the party you
love i thought she was the one trying to
rise above this kind of um mudslinging
uh so those weren't penny's words uh
that was something that was retweeted
tweeted that was in a one of our
broadsheet uh papers um absolutely penny
throughout has been somebody who's risen
above what has been a really difficult
campaign
i think today is an opportunity to make
sure that we get two people on the
ballot paper who believe um who offer
our membership a choice and penny will
be the person who's there with with deep
and clear integrity but also we're the
first person in the generation who's
actually won her seat from labor and
will become prime minister okay very
swiftly pat mcfadden when i've got you
who would you most like to
face or actually i should say who would
you be most frightened of facing a
general election
none of them they're all going to try
and claim their fresh start none of them
are a fresh start it's 12 years for tory
prime ministers we are not in good shape
and i'm afraid changing the person at
the top
isn't going to change that unless we get
a much bigger change in direction okay
uh thank you uh very much the panel
today there maria miller helen morgan
and pat mcfadden thank you well we're
joined now by our political editor beth
rigby to look ahead to boris johnson's
final prime minister's questions what
are you expecting well i think pat you
just delighted on what the attack lines
for labour will be which will be that
video you put out uh overnight with some
of the uh the the criticisms that other
conservative candidates have put towards
each other uh during those two televised
debates so i think kirsten is going to
have a lot of material going into pmq's
today to talk about the way
conservative party uh leaders if you
like and and leading figures have been
talking down uh their record in
government so good fodder for kierstarma
but look the big thing uh today will be
it's boris johnson's last prime
minister's questions and i imagine he
might be sitting there not quite
believing that having won that 80-seat
majority back in december 2019 he finds
himself uh booted out and preparing for
his final pmqs and i'll also be looking
to see if liz truss is sitting right by
his side which i imagine she will be for
this final pmqs as they scramble
and really scramble
for votes ahead of that key vote
at 4pm when we should know who's going
to be in the run-off subject to a
tie-breaker which i can't even get my
head around yet yeah the voting
yesterday was quite difficult to get a
heads around as well and it does feel a
bit of a strange position where we're
obviously focusing on the prime
minister's questions now boris johnson's
last victory lap if you like but all
eyes will be on what happens this
afternoon yeah of course i mean this is
the moment where uh it's decided which
will be in the runoff and i've been
calling mps this morning and genuinely
people are saying to me it's just too
close to call it's unclear whether
there's a bit of skull duggary going on
in terms of lending votes campaigns to
stop different candidates lots of head
scratching as to how tom tougan had
possibly picked up
or liz trust possibly picked up 14 votes
uh from tim tougan hack uh yesterday so
lots of head scratching about that uh
did some of his column move uh to liz
and are they going to move back to penny
morden did they move to rishi sunak and
rishi lent them out to to liz but
there's also the big question about
where does the bad or not vote go now
critically kemi badanok and michael gove
who was her key backer haven't come out
for anyone uh today kemi said vote with
your heart and i think from the mordance
team perspective they think that they
can sell that penny as the change
candidate picks them up liz will be
wanting to pick some up uh rishi will be
wanting to pick some up so it's still
too close i think to call uh who's gonna
be the final two but i think from the
trust team point of view they will be
happy from last night that they have
momentum going in to the final ballot
the problem for rishi sunak is even if
he can get through on the mps as it
stands at the moment the party would
prefer either woman above him so he
might get to the final two might be the
mp's favorite but he is going to have a
really uphill struggle to win over the
membership so it really is wide open i
guess that's i guess the second place is
all the more important just because of
that exactly and we're just waiting and
to see boris johnson obviously uh he's
entered at the house of commons we're
expecting to see him stand up uh and
deliver that final prime minister's
questions any moment now do you think it
it'll be a bit of a victory lap from him
today oh i'm sure that he will roll out
his uh greatest hits today is he is that
him standing on that cat's eyes are
going i'm sure he will want to talk
about some of his greatest hits he'll
probably want to talk about the vaccine
rollout that big majority uh he will
want to talk about leveling up he might
want to talk too about urging the
whoever succeeds him to continue his
agenda and i think that's a big debate
in the party now do they want liz trust
who's seen by rivals as continuity boris
johnson or do they want something new
he's retiring yeah and like you say um
saying earlier i think all eyes to see
on who's sitting next to him is it going
to be liz trust and do you think he'll
even try and steer the debate uh to
influence what happens later
well i think behind the scenes um people
around boris johnson are phoning around
mps i've been told uh urging them to
back liz trust to stop rishi sonak i
mean that has been the theme of the past
couple of weeks liz trust has been his
anointed candidate uh one rival who
doesn't like her much did actually say
to me this morning that they see her as
continuity boris without the charisma
which is a bit cutting but
that's what rivals worry about that she
can't win over the public even if she
wins the race let's have a little
listening i think there's something
happening always we'll be remembered for
what this house did and the way that you
conducted those duties during those dark
times
[Music]
i understand that members will have
differing views about the prime
minister's performance and legacy and
those views will be sincerely and
passionately held but i remind members
that our constituents others around the
world watch these proceedings let us
conduct them in a respectful manner
focusing on issues and policies rather
than personalities i remember i take
this opportunity to remind members of
the words of asking me good temper and
moderation of the characteristics of the
parliamentary debate i expect to see
that reflected today in the proceedings
i now call kim ledbeter
question number one mr speaker
prime minister thank you mr speaker
today marks the 40th anniversary of the
bombings in hyde park and regent park
and tomorrow sees the 50th anniversary
of bloody friday
such terror by the provisional ira was
barbaric and shameful bringing untold
grief to countless families and our
thoughts are with all those who lost
loved ones during the troubles we as the
government remain determined to help
build a better shared future for all the
people of northern ireland
mr speaker i've spoken to the chair of
the national fire council last night and
this morning about the heroic work of
firefighters in recent days
i know the whole house will want to
thank them and all our frontline
services who've been working hard to
keep us safe
my right honourable friend the
chancellor of the duchy of lancaster
will be making an oral statement later
mr speaker i know colleagues which would
join me wishing england's lionesses well
in their quarter-final match
against spain in brighton this evening
and i know that the house will want to
congratulate jake whiteman
who produced a stunning run to take gold
in the 1500 meters of the world
championships in oregon mr speaker as
you rightly say last week i i told the
house that this was possibly uh the last
week was possibly my last pmq's this
week mr speaker probably
certainly i will be
my last bmq's from this dispatch box uh
or any other this bad boss
mr speaker this morning i had meetings
with ministerial colleagues and others
and in addition to my duties in this
house i will have further such meetings
later today
thank you mr speaker summer recess gives
all parliamentarians an opportunity to
reflect on our inability to uphold the
seven principles of public life
selflessness openness objectivity
honesty integrity accountability and
leadership these are fine principles but
public trust in politicians is at an
all-time low
will the prime minister be using the
next few weeks to personally consider
why this could be
and as the unedifying fight for his job
continues
if those who are vying to replace the
group were to draw on his wise counsel
if those who are vying to replace him
would draw on his wise household and why
wouldn't they
what advice would he give to ensure the
people we serve receive far better than
they have from this government
oh well mr speaker i'm afraid i didn't
quite catch the last uh bit of the
honorable ladies question but i i will
be using i will be using the next few
weeks to do what i think the uh the
people of this country would expect and
that is drive forward uh the agenda on
which we were elected
in 2019 and of which i think the labour
party particularly fear the conservative
party and that is the agenda and that is
the agenda of uniting and leveling up
and making sure that we invest in places
that for decades were betrayed by labor
and left behind and that is what the
conservatives are going to do and that's
why we're going to win again
[Applause]
russia's war in ukraine continues now
turkey have withdrawn its opposition to
sweden and finland joining nato
so what assessment does my right
honorable friend make about the short
and long-term securities of europe now
this has happened
private i thank my honourable friend for
that uh excellent question the accession
of both countries i think will
be good for them i think it will
encourage uh or it will make all our
allies safer and i think it will make
the whole of the uh euro atlantic uh
security area uh stronger mr speaker and
i i'm proud of the role that the uk has
played in that accession
we now come to the leader of the
opposition here's stop
can i start by saying to the prime
minister
that i do know that the relationship
between a prime minister and leader of
the opposition is never easy
and this one's proved no exception to
the rule
but i would like to take this
opportunity to wish him his wife and his
family the best for the future
can i also put on record our gratitude
to the fire and rescue services for all
their courageous work yesterday in
extreme temperatures
all our thoughts are with those affected
by the fires
particularly those that have lost their
homes i joined the prime minister in his
comments about the bombings in hyde park
and the ira warmings
i also join him in his comments about
the lionesses the coverage starts at 7
30 tonight on bbc one and i'm sure the
whole country will be roaring them on
and for anyone who doesn't fancy
football eastenders is on
so if you'd rather watch outrageous
characters taking lumps out of it
themselves you've got a choice
albert square or the tory leadership
debates on catch-up
or on that topic mr speaker
why
why does the prime minister think that
those vying to replace him decided to
pull out of the sky debate last night
[Applause]
well
mr speaker
i i i i'm not following this thing
particularly closely but my
my my my impression my impression is
that there's been a quite a lot of
debate already and i think the public i
think the public are having they're
having an ample opportunity to view the
talent uh mr speaker that
anyone of any one of which any one of
which will as i say before like some
household detergent would wipe the floor
[Applause]
today's happens to be just about the
anniversary of the exit from lockdown
last year and do you remember do you
remember what he said uh he said yeah
i'm gonna remind him he said it was
reckless it was because we were able to
take that decision mr speaker supported
by every single one of those
conservative candidates opposed by him
that we had the fastest economic growth
in the g7 we're now able to help
families up and down for the country if
we listen to him it wouldn't have been
possible mr speaker and i don't think
they'll be listening to him either
[Applause]
well i'm impressed you managed to get
through that with a straight face
actually
i think the truth is this
they organized the tv debates because
they thought it'd be a great chance for
the public to hear from the candidates
first hand yeah then disaster struck
because the public actually heard from
the candidates firsthand
but but i am interested
uh in what he makes of the battle for
his job so let me start with a simple
one does the prime minister agree with
his former chancellor
that plans put forward by the other
candidates are in his words i've got
them here nothing more than the fantasy
economics of unfunded spending promises
[Applause]
well well mr speaker they know all about
fantasy economics because
they've committed already they've
already committed to 94 billion pounds
of extra tax and uh and spending uh mr
speaker which every household in this
country would have to pay for to the
tune of about 2 100 pounds it's thanks
to the uh the former chancellor's
management of the economy thanks
discovers management of the economy we
had growth in may of north point i don't
make 0.5
we have more people
in paid employment than any time in the
history of this country mr speaker and i
leave i'm i'm proud to be leaving office
right now with unemployment at or near a
50-year low
when they left office it was at 8 that's
the difference between them and us
[Applause]
mr speaker
every labour pledge made under my
leadership is fully costed those buying
those buying to protect him
they
mr speaker
vying to replace him have racked up
330 billion pounds of unfunded spending
commitments
but i do know that the prime minister
didn't agree with his former chancellor
so what about his foreign secretary
she was withering about the government's
economic record
she said again her words here they are
if rishi has got this great plan for
growth
why haven't we seen it in the last two
and a half years at the treasury
that's a fair question is it prime
minister
yeah
mr speaker i think that everybody would
uh agree that what you saw in the last
two and a half years was because of the
pandemic the biggest fallen output for
biggest fallen output for 300 years
which this government dealt with and
coped with
magnificently
by by distributing vaccines faster than
any other european government faster
than any other major economy which would
not have been possible if we had
listened to him and that's why mr
speaker we have the fiscal firepower
that is necessary to help families up
and down the country making tax cuts for
virtually everybody paying national
insurance contributions the difference
between
labour and the conservative speaker is a
crucial philosophical difference under
labour families on low incomes get most
of their income from benefits under us
they get most of it from earnings
because we believe jobs jobs jobs that's
the difference mr speaker
mr speaker inflation is up again this
morning and millions are struggling with
the cost of living crisis and he he's
decided to come down from his gold
wallpapered bunker for one last time
to tell us that everything's fine i am
going to miss the delusion
but his foreign secretary didn't stop
there mr speaker she also said that the
former chancellor's 15 tax rises are
leading the country into recession
and the member for portsmouth north was
even more scathing
she said again her words
our public services are in a desperate
state
we can't continue with what we've been
doing because it clearly isn't working
has the prime minister told her
who's been running our public services
for the last 12 years
[Applause]
mr speaker this is absolutely again he's
doing this completely satirical this is
the government this is the government
that is investing
650 billion pounds uh in infrastructure
in skills in technology he talks about
public services what really matters to
people this country right now is getting
there getting their appointments getting
their operations fixing the copic
battles that's what we're doing fixing
the ambulances that's what he should be
talking about mr speaker and that's why
we voted through that's why we passed
the 39 billion pound health and care
levy mr speaker which they opposed
every time something needs to be done mr
speaker they try to oppose it he's just
a great pointless human bollard mr
speaker that's what he is
mr speaker if only if only it was
satirical
it's what the future candidates think of
is mr speaker
we want to get through pmq's because
there's quite a few of you wanting to
catch my eye it will be what help will
get through in order to do that kirsten
i appreciate they may not want to hear
what their future leader thinks of their
record in government but i think the
country needs to know if only it were
satirical prime minister it's what the
candidates think of the record yeah but
among the mudslinging there was one very
important point because the member for
safran walden claimed that she warned
the former chancellor that he was
handing taxpayer money directly to
fraudsters in covid loans
she says
he dismissed her worries
and that as a result he cost the
taxpayer 17 billion pounds
does the prime minister think that she's
telling the truth
okay this is the one of the last blasts
from captain hindsight and mr speaker
because uh at least at least to me at
least to me because because they were
the party i remember they were the party
who was who are so so desperate uh for
us to be uh hiring their friends to get
to with ppe they wanted a football agent
uh to supply
a theatrical costumia to supply ppe do
you remember mrs mr speaker we we had to
get that stuff at record speed uh we
produced 408 billion pounds worth of
support for families and for businesses
up and down the country mr speaker and
the only reason we were able to do it at
such speed is because we've managed the
economy in a sensible and moderate way
and labor every time they've left office
is with unemployment higher they're
economically illiterate mr speaker and
they would wreck the economy
i think the message coming out of this
leadership contest is pretty clear
they've got us into this mess and
they've no idea how to get us out of it
the foreign secretary says we can't go
on with our current economic policy
the member for portsmouth north bemoaned
the fact that what we've been doing has
not been good enough
and the member for safran walden
probably puts it best when she simply
asked
why should the public trust us we
haven't exactly covered ourselves in
glory their words
their future leaders words
they've trashed every part of their
record in government from dental care
and ambulance response times to the
highest taxes in 70 years
what message does it send when the
candidates be prime minister can't find
a single decent thing to say about him
about each other or their record in
government
mr speaker what does it say
what does he what does he say about him
that no one can name a single policy of
the late after three years of the labour
opposition apart from putting up taxes
he's one of those pointless plastic
bollards you find
around around a deserted road works on a
motorway mr speaker we got brexit done
he voted against it 48 times we got this
country far side of kobe in spite of
everything uh he would have kept and
when he would have kept us in long time
we're fixing social care mr speaker when
they have no plan and no ideas of their
own and we're now bringing forward
measures
with in the face of strikes to outlaw
wildcat strikes mr speaker i can tell
you to outlaw wildcat strikes i can tell
you why i can tell you why he does that
that funny wooden flapping gesture i'll
tell you why he does that funny wooden
fabric because mr speaker he's got he's
uh he's got the union barons pulling his
strings from beneath him
a hundred million pounds mr speaker
we've restored our democracy and our
independence uh we've got this country
through kovid and i'm proud to say that
when it comes to tackling climate change
or sticking up for ukraine we have led
the world on the international stage and
i want to thank my friends and
colleagues on these benches for
everything that they have done
[Applause]
mr speaker
in in september it will be 25 years
since the annivers
the 25th anniversary of the referendum
on devolution in both scotland and wales
one in 20 people in england and the nhs
have been waiting for for more than a
year in wales that's one in five
and school leaders in wales 75 of whom
say that they don't have enough capital
to maintain their existing buildings
regardless of building any others
in his final opportunity at the dispatch
box will the prime minister and the
minister for the union agree
that in terms of wales at least
devolution has been a disaster
prime minister speaker i want evolution
to to work but i think and i've had some
good conversations with mark drakeford
but the devolved authorities
particularly labour in wales need to do
their job properly
welcome to the leader of the smp in
blackfoot
thank you mr speaker and can i join you
in wishing all the best in his impending
retirement to james mackay and beth here
he's been a friend to many of us right
throughout this house and we
congratulate him for his service can i
also join the prime minister in
congratulating
jake whiteman for his success overnight
and winning the 1500 meters at the world
champions what a fantastic achievement
mr speaker this week
has seen historic records set across the
united kingdom
but let's look at the prime minister's
record-breaking efforts in office
history brexit slash 31 billion pounds
from the economy the biggest fall in
living standards
since the 1970s
people's pay in real terms falling at
the fastest rate on records with the
worst economic growth forecast in the
g20 outside russia and the highest
inflation
in 40 years
personally
i'd like to thank the prime minister in
his capacity as minister of the union
for driving support for independence
to new heights
mr speaker
westminster is holding scotland back
the economy is failing and this prime
minister has driven us to the brink of a
recession
isn't it this case that the prime
minister's legacy of catastrophic
mismanagement has paved the way for the
end of the union
[Applause]
speaker that's not what i uh observe and
he talks about records i'll point to the
fastest vaccine rollout in europe those
unemployment as i've said uh for uh at
all near 50 years youth unemployment
fastest growth in the g7 last year in
spite of everything as for the scottish
uh national nationalist record just look
at look at where where they are they're
i'm afraid to say scottish uh school
standards are not what they should be
because of the failure of the snp uh
they're failing they're failing they're
failing people who are tragically
addicted addicted to drugs and mr
speaker in scotland and the people of
scotland are facing another 900 million
pounds in tax because of the
mismanagement of the snp
the prime minister might believe that
nonsense but the people of scotland
don't because they know the reality that
our nhs is the best performing in the
united kingdom and education standards
under the snp are moving in the right
direction
well
well mr speaker that's a that's a good
look to the people of scotland the
disdain that the tories show for our
country mr speaker i hope that the prime
minister
has time to reflect on his conduct in
office with all his new spare time and i
genuinely hope that he finds some peace
of mind
the fact is
that as well as a record breaker
the prime minister is a rule breaker
illegally shutting down parliament
partying through the pandemic
handing out ppe contracts to cronies
unilaterally changing the ministerial
code
and let us not forget mr speaker the
prime minister is still under
investigation because he can't be
trusted to tell the truth
shameful disgraceful and a complete
waste of scotland's time
this is how the people of scotland will
remember this prime minister
isn't it the case that the prime
minister and his government should have
had its last day a long time ago
quite simply downing street is no place
for a law breaker
well look mrs biggie's i think on the
the points he's the personal abuse stuff
i i think he's talking a load of tosh
but when he's when he's up
but when he's up when he's up in it when
he's retired
his croft
which may be all too soon uh there's a
thing i i hope that he will reflect on
his long-running campaign to break up
the greatest country in the world and i
hope he will reflect on the on the
pointlessness of what he uh is trying to
do and think instead about the
priorities of the people of scotland
which i think are about all the issues
uh that he thought would trigger about
their education about crime mr speaker
and about the about the burden of
taxation that they are unnecessarily
placing on the people of scotland
welcome
a long time ago when i trained as a
pilot i had the luxury of being able to
fly around turbulent storms
and but what i also had was the ability
to to rely on a team that kept my
aircraft air worthy
as the prime minister prepares his new
flight plans could i suggest that he
might reset his compass to true north
and stops off in dudley where he will
always be welcomed with open arms with
sincere affection and where he will be
able to see the legacy
[Applause]
and uh i thank him for that that renewed
invitation mrs d i've spent many happy
days with him in dudley and uh let's
hope that there are more to come
and davey
as the prime minister leaves office
i'm sure the whole house is looking
forward to him completing his book on
shakespeare
we wait to read what he really thinks
about tragic figures
brought down by their vaulting ambition
or scheming politicians who conspire to
bring down a tyrannical leader
the candidates mr speaker now plotting
to take his place
all profess that they will bring a fresh
start
a clean break from his government
but does the prime minister not agree
with me
that a fresh start
and a clean break
would require a new mandate from the
british people
and before they strut and threat their
hour upon the stage there should be a
general election
[Applause]
[Music]
mrs mr speaker i i think that polonius
that's who he is uh what you need more
matter with less art mr speaker uh
uh
the the only thing the only thing you
need to know if there were to be a
general election of course the liberal
democrats will rightly get thrashed
because that would be
that is that is the moment that is the
moment that is the moment when the
public actually look with horror and
what liberal democrat policies really
are
and and i know and all and all these
rural voters would discover the massive
green taxes uh that they would like to
apply uh and the only risk is that there
could be some kind of crackpot coalition
between those guys and the dems and the
scottish nationalists
to put that into effect that is what we
must prevent
thank you mr speaker my constituents
feel very let down by the mayor of
london
he is consulting on cutting 18
of london's buses the met is in special
measures he's looking to sell notting
hill police station to the highest
bidder and he is looking to push through
a completely unwanted over development
of south kensington tube station does my
right honorable friend agree with me
that londoners deserve way way better
mr speaker london once had a mayor who
cut crime uh by 25
and cut the murder rate uh by 30
and built twice as many affordable homes
as the current incumbent and what london
needs is another conservative mayor
jamie stone
thank you very much mr speaker
could i just add a personal load of
thanks to lord mackay of clash phone who
is retiring he is a highland gentleman
and he's been very very helpful to me
for a number of years and i'm extremely
grateful
mr speaker the prime minister knows that
harnessing willpower wind power
is crucial to united kingdom
the prime minister also knows
that the highlands have faced great
historic difficulties over the years
so i hope the prime minister agrees with
me
that a green freeport
in the comedy firth is vital to
harnessing wind energy it has the full
support of the industry and vital
prosperity of that
region i thank you very much i can
confirm that we're committed to funding
two uh free new green free ports in
scotland to the 252 million pounds
wouldn't be possible of course if the
smp got their way and we returned to the
eu
jay barry thank you mr speaker can i
congratulate
my friend on his work to tackle regional
inequality in this country through his
leveling up agenda
and as he rightly reflects with pride
this summer on the work of both himself
and his government
will he also urge
all candidates in this leadership
election and all colleagues in this
house
to further drive forward that leveling
up agenda to tackle inequality wherever
it is found within this united kingdom
[Applause]
i i hardly agree with my honourable
friend mr speaker and it's not just my
right home friend it's not just
inequality it's inequality of
opportunity and that's what leveling up
addresses johnny lloyd said
thank you mr speaker you know very few
people in the north of england believe
that the leveling up agenda has achieved
anything at all now the prime minister
has a few days left in office can he use
this to drive through the the
transponder and rail system that we were
promised would be finished in 2019 and
will not be finished before 2013. it's a
shambles and he is responsible
actually mr speaker this government's
responsible uh for three new high-speed
lines including a northern powerhouse
rail which no previous government has
done
carolina thank you mr speaker my right
honourable friend rightly paid tribute
to our hard-working firefighters dealing
with the fires over the last few days in
this unprecedented weather will my right
honourable friend take action to make
sure more fires can be prevented by
getting rid of disposable barbecues and
chinese skylanders
the ones that flow right thank you i
thank my my own very much for her
suggestions i think the key thing is for
people uh to behave responsibly first uh
with the use of these things it's
clearly insane to take a a disposable
barbecue onto dry grass yeah dr philippa
whitford thank you very much mr speaker
due to scottish government investment in
affordable housing the scottish child
payment and extended free school meals
scotland has the lowest level of child
poverty in the uk
in contrast to the northeast which has
risen by 50 percent on the watch of this
government in contrast the prime
minister took over a thousand pounds
from the poorest families so much for
leveling up and those fighting to
replace him have been falling over
themselves to promise tax cuts to the
wealthy
so if the uk is meant to be a voluntary
union does he not recognize that voters
in scotland have the right to a
referendum so they can choose a fairer
future
[Applause]
actually mr speaker we increased the
living wage across the whole of the uk
uh by a thousand pounds and we made sure
that people on universal credit uh got
their tax bills cut uh by a thousand
pounds and and we've in the last couple
of weeks we've cut uh we've cut national
insurance contributions by an average of
330 pounds and it was because of the
union that we were able to support
families up and down uh the country in
scotland uh with the follow and other
payments to the tune of 408 billion
pounds mr speaker andrew barway
can i thank my right honourable friend
for his commitment to scotland and the
entire united kingdom over his uh
years
in downhill and to him and my friend the
secretary of state for scotland for
improving and increasing the visibility
and involvement of the uk government in
scotland over the past three years and
does my right honourable friend agree
with me that whoever takes his job and
whatever comes next the united kingdom
will always be stronger together than it
ever would be upon
[Applause]
[Music]
the windrush compensation scheme was
launched in april 2019. in the time
since we've seen this prime minister
come and go meanwhile just one in four
applicants have received compensation so
far and at least 28 have sadly passed
away without receiving compensation
isn't it about time for the government
to make the scheme independent of the
home office and finally provide justice
to the victims before it is too late
and actually mr speaker i think more
people have got conversation
renew my apologies to the windrush uh
generation for what they they've
suffered but we have greatly uh
increased the compensation available uh
we've paid out i think more than 51
million pounds we're working with
voluntary groups uh to ensure that
people get what they're entitled to but
i may say uh that labor has never
apologized for their own part in the
windrush scandal
speaker can i thank my outro friend the
prime minister for all of the work he
has done for skunk but can i pay
particular thanks to him for the work
that he has done for steele
he has shown his understanding both of
the challenges that steele faces and of
its importance to this nation he has
kept every promise he has made to me on
steel and i want to thank him very much
for his work on that does he agree with
me that the future of steel is always
safest under a conservative government
[Applause]
uh yes mr speaker and i thank her for
everything that she has done to champion
uk steel a vital national industry
mr speaker this prime minister has been
the very embodiment of the excess and
device that the ministerial code was
designed to protect and once trust is
broken it's very hard to rebuild the
trust of the good friday agreement
between the peoples between the
governments of these islands has been
systematically destroyed over the last
six years and people across the island
of ireland whether unionist or
nationalist or neither have looked on in
horror at the degradation of the rule of
law at the deterioration of anglo-irish
relationships and at the bolstering of
the far right many of us will work to
try and restore those relationships and
ensure the decent people of britain and
ireland live entwined lives for many
years to come can i ask the prime
minister if he is capable of any
self-reflection does he have any regrets
of his legacy of damaging our fragile
shared society and all the people of
northern ireland
oh well mr speak i completely uh
disagree with that uh the the the whole
objective of the uh of the northern
ireland protocol bill that we've passed
is to support the uh belfast good friday
uh arrangements to support the balance
uh of those and symmetry of those racial
lines very pleased that uh it passed its
uh uh it got its advance into the house
laws with no amendments mr speaker
chris bible
mr speaker in recalling the situation
the prime minister inherited in july
uh 2019 of a a parliament with a
majority determined to frustrate the
result of the 2016 referendum uh led by
a speaker who was just slightly partial
um and the seemingly impossible
situation we found uh does my right
horrible friend understand that he has
uh the gratitude of my constituents that
can identify the wood from the trees and
myself for his leadership over the last
year
[Applause]
speak
i'm very i'm very grateful to my mother
i'm a friend and uh
you know there's a fair amount of wood
on the opposite bench and i think that's
why we will prevail in the next general
election yeah all right
uh thank you mr speaker since 2014 the
tory party have had more prime ministers
than we've had referendums may i remind
the pm
of the smith commission report it states
it is agreed by all parties that nothing
in this report prevents scotland
becoming an independent country
therefore does the prime minister
believe in a democracy
and will he respect the people of
scotland's right to self-determination
i think that uh the people of scotland
do not frankly want to be talking about
constitutional issues when there are
when uh another referendum uh when the
issues before the country are [ __ ] the
cost of living uh the educational issues
that we discussed drugs crime mr speaker
i think they're far more pressing
mark francois thank you mr speaker
the prime minister spoke earlier about
the atrocities carried out by the ira
for decades many men and women
had the courage to put on the queen's
uniform and uphold
law and order in northern ireland on
operation banner
one of the prime minister's
undoubted achievements
is he brought in the northern ireland
legacy bill
so that those people who serve their
country
can finally sleep safely in their beds
thank you for that prime minister if i
may be so presumptuous on their behalf
you kept your word
[Applause]
i'd like to thank my old friend for
everything he did to campaign on that
issue for uh for so long and i'm glad
that this government was indeed able to
fulfill its promise uh not just to the
uh veterans uh but to their families as
well i would like to uh renew my thanks
uh to the security services who do so
much to keep us safe but also to all
those who put on the queen's uniform
yeah molly calvin thank you very much mr
speaker
prime minister of the oecd forecaster uk
economy with zero growth in gdp for 2023
that'll be the worst performance in the
g7
ireland switzerland norway denmark the
netherlands iceland sweden austria
belgium and finland are all wealthier
than the uk
why should scotland not be afforded the
same opportunity to seek prosperity
through being a sovereign independent
nation standing as an eco amongst other
equal nations
mr speaker the uk i was the fastest in
the g7 last year we'll return to the uh
top of the table uh soon
because we came out of covid fastest 0.5
growth in may miss speaker and the
people of scotland don't forget the
people of scotland like the people the
whole of the uk are supported by the
massive fiscal firepower of the uk
treasury
and that is a great advantage show them
mccrory
mr speaker can i place on record my
thanks particularly to the firefighters
of cornwall who were also extremely busy
and courageous yesterday yeah yeah um
can i thank this prime minister for his
support and enthusiasm for cornwall and
for the people of cornwall over the last
few years not least for the hosting of
the g7 last year and can i also thank
him for the investment of the self um of
the shared prosperity fund an investment
of 132 million pounds which for an
average national average of 17 pounds
ahead cornwall sees 233 pounds ahead and
does my right-hand friend agree that his
enthusiasm for leveling up every part of
the united kingdom needs to carry on in
the future
yes uh she's a fantastic champion my
friend is a fantastic champion for for
cornwall and we will continue with our
program to support the greater southwest
whether it's through the uh the a303 or
broadband uh mr speaker cornwall has a
bright future uh with her as a
representative justin oswald
thank you mr speaker well the prime
minister has been on the random at
checkers people in scotland are
suffering because of this tory cost of
living crisis and we're paying a high
price for his disastrous hard brexit
imposed against the wishes of scottish
voters
it's time to end this democracy denial
prime minister scotland's can't afford
to stay shackled to this crumbling union
and tory governments that we don't vote
for
does the prime minister not accept that
scotland is a democracy he has no right
to overrule the votes of people in
scotland and we will have the referendum
that we voted for
uh mr speaker this is the uh the country
that uh secured uh furlough that
delivered the vaccine across the whole
of the of the uk while the snp gets on
with over taxing uh to the tune of 900
million pounds mr speaker that's what
they're over taxing in scotland and we
had a referendum mr speaker in 2014.
martin because
thank you mr speaker i know that my
right honourable friend is aware of how
important the seafood processing
industry is to the grimsby kleethorpe's
area
however there is one cloud on the
horizon and that is the recently imposed
35 percent tariff on white fish which is
causing industry leaders considerable
concern and though they recognize that
it's important to maintain sanctions
against russia this is causing as i say
great concern would the marathon
befriend
arrange meetings with me and and my
honorable friend from grimsby with the
appropriate ministers so we can discuss
messages how to mitigate the impact on
the industry
i'll make sure he gets a meeting as soon
as possible with the relevant minister
but i think it is very important that we
uh encourage our great fish and chips
shops in uh in grimsey kleethorpe and
elsewhere uh to make sure they're not
just using uh russian uh fish and chips
john littlestone
thank you mr speaker as the prime
minister limps off into the history
books
his name up there in the pantheon of
greats alongside the duke of portland
and spencer percival
can he update us on his defenestration
honours list how many of his cronies
will lean over
can we expect him can we expect him to
surpass harold wilson
with a lavender list of dodgy donors
obsequious courtiers and pinchers by
nature
[Music]
mr speaker i'm sure that everybody who
has
served this government loyally and well
deserves recognition of some kind
but as for the honors list i'm afraid
he'll have to contain uh his excitement
can i just say we wanted good temper and
better moderate language yes and i don't
think we've got it then
right well i know within an affair
speaker i'd like to thank the prime
minister for his support for the new
city of south end
our brilliant hospital turns 90 next
tuesday but our heroic nhs staff are
hampered by the size of the a e
department conservative led capital
funding of 8.4 million to expand the a e
department was promised five years ago
but has not quite arrived will my right
honorable friend encourage the new
the new health secretary to give us the
best birthday present ever and in the
words of cuba good and junior show me
order i think the prime minister's got
the message also i'd like i'd like to
hear your you
brilliant champions in the hospital uh i
know the case is under uh review by the
uh department but never forget it's only
possible because of the money uh that
this government is investing
go around david
mr speaker the prime minister will be
remembered as a man of his word
high
200 000 dead the highest in europe
[Music]
f
f business
for
this is the truth they don't like it
[Applause]
let's listen to the truth
400 000 fewer people in jobs than before
the pandemic if you include the
self-employed which the prime minister
doesn't so will he now keep faith to the
3.7 million people who taken out student
loans since this conservative government
was in power who now face rising
inflation in terms of rent in terms of
heating in terms of eating who now must
pay
seven
[Applause]
listen to
[Applause]
when i stand it sees if you sit down it
helps all of the children i want to get
sent the question i know he's going
right to the end now go around davis
the 3.7 million people who face seven
percent interest rates from september as
well as the inflational heating and
eating and rent when mortgages are two
percent will he help those people in
need or will he help the city people who
are making his friends making all this
money out of the cost of living crisis
mr speaker i'll tell you what students
want they want to be able to have a
system where they don't pay back more
than they borrow and that's what we're
putting in but they want to make sure
also mr speaker that they have a jobs
market uh that will take them on with
high-wage high-skilled jobs and the
difference between them and us is that
we get people into high-wage
high-skilled jobs they're prepared to
let them languish on the dole mr speaker
and that is the difference
final questions to redwood lee
on behalf of the house
may i thank the prime minister
[Applause]
on behalf
of the house man i thank the prime
minister
for his three years record of
service on behalf of some of the most
vulnerable people in the country
can i thank him
for his insistence on rolling out the
astrazeneca jab which has saved
on behalf of
17.4 million people who voted brexit may
i thank him for restoring people's
belief in democracy
on behalf of northern towns may i thank
him for his commitment to leveling up
and most of all
on behalf of the people of ukraine
may i thank him for holding high the
torch of freedom and ensuring that that
country is not a vassal state
for true grit and determination keep
going and thank you
i want to thank my right honourable
friend
and i want to give
i want to i want to use the last few
seconds mr speaker to give some words of
advice to uh to my successor whoever he
or she
may be number one stay close to the
americans stick up for the ukrainians
stick up for freedom and democracy
everywhere cut taxes and deregulate
wherever you can to make this the
greatest place to live and invest which
it is
i love the treasury but remember that if
we'd always listened to the treasury we
wouldn't have built the m25 or the
channel tunnel focus
focus on the road ahead
focus on the road ahead but always
remember to check the rear view mirror
and remember
remember
above all it's not twitter that counts
it's the people that sent us here and
yes sir the last few years have been the
greatest privilege of of my life and
it's true that i i helped to get the
biggest tory majority for 40 years and
a huge realignment in uk politics mr
speaker we've transformed our democracy
and restored our national independence
as my normal friend said we've helped
i've helped to get this country through
a pandemic and help save another country
from barbarism and frankly that's enough
to be going on with
mission largely accomplished
for now
i want to thank you uh mr speaker i want
to thank all the wonderful staff of the
house comms i want to thank all my
friends and colleagues i want to thank
my old friend uh opposite and mr speaker
i want to thank everybody here and
hasta la vista
thank you
oh
we now come to the statement
i'm looking for mr maltos
he's here well that was boris johnson's
very final prime minister's questions
after three years as a leader you can
see there kit malt house coming in
the chance of the duchy of lancaster due
to give an update
on the government's heatwave response
and beth really that promises questions
as you anticipated dominated by the fact
that all kissed arms attack line seemed
to be written by the written by the by
the uh candidates uh seeking to replace
him and that was very uncomfortable for
all of the conservative benches as uh
the attacks on each other were rolled
out by kierstar mchenry badanox saying
we haven't covered ourselves in glory
why should the public trust as liz trust
taking aim at sonic over
tax rises rishi taking aim at her over
fancy economics and the prime minister's
words has asta la vida baby okay we're
going to have to go straight to uh
thank you very much jay when it
registered a provisional reading of 40.3
degrees celsius
according to the met office no fewer
than 34 locations around the united
kingdom exceeded the country's previous
highest temperature of 37.8 celsius set
in 2019.
we have seen a collective national
endeavor to prepare for and manage the
effects of the heat from town hall to
whitehall and across various industries
to keep people safe and infrastructure
functioning
from water companies and rail engineers
to public servants right across the land
everyone has pulled together with
members of the public responding in a
way that was responsible and took the
pressure off vital public services
our national resolve has been
exemplified by our fire and rescue
services
for many of whom yesterday was the
busiest day since world war ii
they were undoubtedly stretched but
coped magnificently and the system put
in place to make sure the fire service
can operate on a national basis as well
as locally worked well
in tinderbox conditions they have dealt
with dozens of wildfires around the
country over the past 24 hours 15 fire
and rescue services declared major
incidents and handled emergency calls
the length and breadth of the country
sadly mr speaker at least 41 properties
have been destroyed in london 14 in
norfolk five in lincolnshire and smaller
numbers elsewhere
on behalf of the prime minister and the
cabinet and i'm sure the whole house i'd
like to pass on our
sincere condolences those who've lost
their homes or business premises and i
know my right-hand friend the secretary
of state is working closely with local
authorities to provide support to them
throughout recent days the prime
minister has monitored our work and has
been specifically briefed on a number of
occasions we did so again this morning
the prime minister was briefed during
the wildfires by mark hardingham chair
of the national fire chiefs council and
the civil contingency secretariat and he
has also passed on his thanks to all the
brave firefighters who sought to control
the flames in such debilitating
conditions
i would also mr speaker like to pay my
tribute to the fire control staff
officers and support teams for their
essential work and the other agencies
that made such tremendous efforts in
recent days the nhs our emergency call
handlers police and maritime and coast
guard agency amongst many others
honourable members will be relieved to
know that some pressure on these
services will now ease
as the fiercest heat has subsided
many incidents are now being scaled back
thunderstorms are likely this afternoon
but for much of the country more clement
dry conditions are the pattern in coming
days the met office however stresses
that the summer is likely to bring
further hot weather and wildfire risk
remains elevated
that is why we're treating this heatwave
as an exacting test of our national
resilience and continuously planning
as always mr speaker there is no room
for complacency
we have seen over the last few days what
you can achieve when you prepare
properly and then work closely together
owing to the technical expertise of the
weather forecasters who predicted with
admirable precision the peak of the heat
wave and how high the temperatures would
be the government was able to launch an
advanced campaign of comprehensive
public advice
and our early data shows how well before
the heatwave arrived people were taking
on board this advice from the uk health
security agency the nhs the chief and
deputy medical chief officer emergency
services and key agencies on the ground
and because of our established local
networks and colleagues in the devolved
administrations we had people spread
across the uk ready to step in when it
matters i am particularly grateful mr
speaker to the for the cooperation
support we receive from the scottish
government welsh government and northern
ireland executive we all need to manage
these events together
now mr speaker i'd like to give some
examples of how people taking the right
action helped to mitigate the effects of
the extreme weather
starting with heeding advice
fully five times as many people accessed
nhs england internet pages on how to
manage the symptoms of heat exhaustion
in the critical week beginning july the
11th that's five times as many moving on
to our vital 999 call services we had
fear that they would come under untold
pressure yet as the mercury climbed
inexorably on july the 18th fewer 999
calls were made than the week before and
more one one one calls again suggesting
that the public had heeded the advice
this time to avoid triple nine unless in
emergencies
and on to travel mr speaker and once
again people were playing for the team
the public stayed at home to avoid the
heat not venturing far the data bears
this out on monday football at major
london stations was around 35
of normal post pandemic levels yesterday
network rail reports passenger train
numbers were around 40 down on the
previous week
we did not forget those who cannot
easily leave their homes either asking
people to look out for the elderly and
vulnerable family members and neighbors
tragically however mr speaker 13 people
are believed to have lost their lives
after getting into difficulty in rivers
reservoirs and lakes while swimming in
recent days
seven of them sadly teenage boys and i
would like like to pass on our sincere
condolences and that of the whole house
to the families of the victims for their
terrible loss
of course we still have work uh to work
through the longer term consequences of
the heat wave the true picture will not
come until all incidents are analyzed
all emergency teams are debriefed and
all incident logs and data reconciled
there is a great deal of data yet to
come in from colleagues in the devolved
administrations and from the local
authorities and agencies around the
country we do recognize mr speaker that
we are likely to experience more of
these incidents and that we should not
underestimate their speed scope and
severity
britain may be uncon accustomed to such
high temperatures but the uk along with
our european neighbors must learn to
live with extreme events such as these
the government has been at the forefront
of the international efforts to reach
net zero but the impacts of climate
change are with us now this is why we
have a national adaptation program under
the leadership of the environment
department as we have seen in recent
days we will continue to face acute
events driven by climate change it is
the responsibility of the cabin office
ministers to coordinate work across
government when these events take place
the government will continue to build
our collective resilience to this end
the national resilience strategy about
which i was asked on monday will be
launched at the earliest possible
opportunity by the incoming
administration
in the meantime i will continue to
coordinate the work of teams across
government in building resilience to
make sure the country is ready to meet
the challenges of the autumn the winter
and beyond and it is in that spirit that
i commend this statement to the house
yeah we now come to the deputy leader of
the opposition angela rainer
thank you mr speaker the events of the
last few days have been incredibly
traumatic for communities across britain
individuals and families have had their
homes destroyed and as the minister says
lives have been lost and as a mother of
teenagers mr speaker i reiterate they
must not swim in our rivers it is too
dangerous for them to do that
farmers and businesses have also seen
their livelihoods go up in smoke we saw
horrifying images of the a2 on fire
yesterday and i want to join the
minister in paying tribute to the
incredible bravery of our fire services
and those whose job it is to head
straight into danger as the rest of us
escape it sadly four firefighters have
been hospitalized in south yorkshire and
over a dozen injured in london i know
the whole house will give them our
gratitude and wish them well
but for too long mr speaker our public
servants have been underappreciated and
undervalued by this government the
minister mentioned our fire services
over the last 10 years their funding and
staffing of the fire and rescue service
has been cut and response times have
gone up by eight percent yesterday no
mutual aid was available to services
facing literal firestorms mr speaker
this statement today is far too late the
impact of this heat wave was completely
predictable why the delay in coming to
this house it has literally taken the
country to go up in flames for the
minister to turn his focus on this
emergency climate change mr speaker will
cause more and more national emergencies
like this from heat waves to fires
floods and pandemics but as we've seen
over the past week the leadership
contenders are doing their hardest to
outbid each other on how they would cut
action on climate change they will leave
us vulnerable to more freak natural
disasters the caretaker minister
opposite says it's his job to chair
cobra meetings but it should be the job
of the prime minister to lead yesterday
the remaining cabinet gave the prime
minister the complete volumes of sir
winston churchill as a leaving gift but
he is no churchill mr speaker he has
been missing in action and can the
minister tell us where he was as the
country burned where was he when cobra
was called last weekend has the prime
minister attended
attended any talks with ministers or
senior officials in the days since isn't
it the truth that the prime minister
this entire government have gone missing
while britain burns
we might have cooler temperatures today
mr speaker but another heat wave is
inevitable as our climate heats up
britain cannot continue to be so
unprepared he tells people to drink
water and wear a hat it's just not good
enough we need a long-term emergency
resilience plan for the future so can
the minister say where is the plan for
delivery of essential servitors how will
people be kept safe at work on transport
in hospitals and in our care homes where
is the guidance for safe indoor working
temperatures he now says the
government's national resilience plan
will be published in due course by the
new administration it's already 10
months overdue mr speaker why should the
british people be forced to wait a whole
year it is the primary duty
of any government to keep the public
safe and britain deserves much better
than this labor has already has a
resilience plan for the long term we
would implement a department-wide
approach and appoint a minister for
resilience we would give local
government the resources they need to
plan and prepare for emergencies and i'd
just like to say that local government
has been on the front line and i pay
tribute to their response to this crisis
and what they did during the pandemic
but their resilience mr speaker has been
eroded by 12 years of cuts and austerity
at the hands of this government and
finally mr speaker
we would labor would empower businesses
and civil society organisation to
strengthen our response
homes have been destroyed
our brave firefighters hospitalized and
lives have been ruined and lost enough
is enough if he's not willing to take
the action mr speaker we on this side of
the house are
[Applause]
minister well mr speaker what a shame uh
that notwithstanding uh the loss of some
homes and obviously some tragic deaths
and water-related incidents the
honourable lady didn't take the
opportunity to recognize that by and
large the system worked
that the planning we put in place and
the resilience that we built into all
those public services and public
servants frankly that she lauded
actually meant that the country got
through this particular extreme weather
event
in
in pretty good shape
we obviously recognized that there were
some unfortunate incidents and as i say
a number of homes that were
set on fire
but the fact that we
kept the damage to a minimum that the
vast majority of the population got
through this difficulty well i was not
recognized by her at all and i think
that's a real shame secondly just to
correct something that she claimed when
she said there was no mutual aid
available this is not correct there was
one
fire rescue service that called for
national mutual aid which was norfolk
and mutual aid was provided from other
parts of the
country
so the
system we have in place for flexing the
use of the fire service across the whole
of the country worked extremely well as
the chair of the national fire chiefs
council was able to confirm to the prime
minister uh last night and indeed this
morning
now the honourable lady seemed to claim
that this was the first time i've turned
up the house it's not it's the second
time i've been in the house to discuss
this
issue and we've been working on this
since the uh weather forecasters um uh
gave us notification that this extreme
weather event was likely to occur it is
however mr speaker the first time the
honourable lady has turned up to the
house
well you were doing a radio station well
being in your office is not being on the
front bench present but not involved i
think is the claim from the labour party
so before she starts flinging stones
maybe she should polish the glass in her
house
before she claims that others are not
doing their job and as to the
involvement of the prime minister he's
been kept in touch with our work
throughout either through personal
briefings by me or indeed last night
this morning briefings by the
chief officer of the national fire
chiefs council and the civil contingency
secretariat she i'm afraid we'll never
know because i hope she's never in
government
number 10 and the cabinet office work
very closely together when these
emergency situations arise and where we
need to put in place plans and specific
coordination work to make sure that we
all understand what the picture
is as far as the resilience plan as i
said the plan is is is in in progress
and will be launched as soon as we get a
new administration into number ten but
she should not risk mistake the
publication of a national resilience
plan uh for us not having any plans at
all as we saw mr speaker in all manner
of areas of the function in our country
the plans that we have in place worked
well the capacity that we stood up
flexed brilliantly often uh to deal with
this ever-changing uh situation and as i
say most of the country uh got through
it in in good shape and as for the
appointment of a minister of resilience
well i'm afraid we already have one it's
me um the job of the chancellor of the
dutch of lancaster the job of the
chancellor of jersey of lancaster's look
after the civil contingency secretariat
which is the zeal specifically with
issues of resilience and make sure the
system works as it did largely yesterday
yeah yeah
james wilde thank you very much mr
speaker yesterday wildfires in northwest
norfolk destroyed properties in branches
the state and also destroyed habitats
and wildlife of the famous wild ken hill
estate that's well known from hosting
the bbc spring watch so can i put on
record my constituents immense thanks to
the norfolk fire service and the other
emergency services as well as all those
in the local community who helped to
tackle these blazers in such awful
circumstances and they will recover and
rebuild those communities and in doing
so will he also reinforce our commitment
to achieve net zero so that we are
better protected from this climate
change
well the honourable gentleman is quite
right that norfolk fire refuse service
was severely tested uh yesterday and
indeed did receive mutual aid i think
from as far afield as merseyside to help
them in that battle and they will uh
stay i understand in situ uh to make
sure that the
norfolk fire rescue service can kind of
get back on its feet and deal with
anything that may come in the next
few days and while we are very focused
on the continuing
elevated risk of wildfires he is quite
right that the long-term work for us
both to make our own contribution to the
battle against climate change but
frankly to lead the world and challenge
some of the biggest polluters in the
world to change their
habits and their uses of fuel is
absolutely critical and i know that in
parliaments to come he will be in the
forefront of that fight
chancellor of the dutch of lancaster
giving a statement on the government's
response to the heatwave after the worst
day of fires since the second world war
he praised the fire services and also
the public response saying that the
government's preparation for the extreme
weather worked labour's angela rainer
disagreed though she said that britain
can't continue to be so unprepared and
there needs to be a long-term plan to
keep people safe
well as we've just been hearing
firefighters in london endured their
busiest day since the second world war
as parts of the capital ignited in the
extreme heat flames ripped through
houses schools and churches and are
continuing to burn across the country
after temperatures topped 40 degrees in
the uk for the first time ever
well in england the fire brigades
declared major incidents in
hertfordshire suffolk norfolk
leicestershire lincolnshire
nottinghamshire parts of yorkshire and
london
in norfolk and in suffolk several fires
started in fields with some then
spreading to houses the far servers
faced a large grass fire and a fire at a
farm in leicestershire as